all right let's talk about the next
steps after Stalin took power he started
to actually implementing some of the
economic some of the policies in this
idea of uh collectivization yeah
what's the story of that in the uh in
the 20s uh leading into the 30s what was
this idea what was the relationship
between the regime the ideology and the
the farmers well there's always been and
obviously very much this day an enormous
amount of
and enmity for lack of a better term
hatred between Ukraine and Russia I mean
this is you know centuries in the making
if not more and the Ukraine or Ukraine
now but at the time the I'm speaking the
region
is and still is the Bread Basket of
Europe it was very fertile lands this is
where the food comes from and this was a
issue also for Lenin as I discussed in
the book because when you had famines
there you know you have famines
throughout uh what later became the
Soviet Union
and the problem is this happened in
North Korea as well in the 90s when they
don't have food if you let in foreigners
and feed your people all of a sudden you
as the government are either Superfluous
or downright
you know deleterious to their well-being
and that's a threat to your power uh so
Lenin let in an American organization
the early 20s which was actually headed
by Herbert Hoover of all people and
after a while Hoover left because he
found that the Bolsheviks were just
taking the grain that the Americans were
giving to feed the people and selling it
for export uh while the people suffered
and one of the people who grew up in
these uh starvation times was a young
Michael Gorbachev where he had you know
I think it's like a quarter or a third
of his village starved to death during
one of these periodic famines
um let Stalin's idea this was a good
mechanism for him to break
the idea of Ukraine being an independent
nation into within its own identity
um and you know he had this kind of
liquidation of the kulaks you know very
famously which thankfully is much more
discussed now than it was maybe when you
and I were kids and akulak the real
meaning or the literal meaning is kind
of this wealthy landowner right but very
quickly it's kind of like it becomes out
group so you know there was a a big
incentive to call someone you didn't
like a kulak and then good luck to you
because now the eyes of the state are on
you and you have to prove that you know
you didn't hire people you you didn't
have four cows or how many acres or so
and so forth they took a huge percentage
of the population the kulaks and they
just deported them you know these are
lands that they had for generations and
they just spread them throughout uh uh
uh broader Russia many of them never
made it and many of them were killed
this was by Design and the dark thing
about the cool Ox like you said when it
becomes abused when it becomes the the
owl group is
foreign
ER than sort of the general right
um farmer peasant and so basically it
gives you a mechanism of resentment
anybody that's better off must be better
off because they're cool let's get rid
of them and it has a
um just from an economics perspective uh
even leaving ethics aside it basically
completely
incentivizes productivity like it wants
you to fail because if you succeed
you're a cool lock and you're going to
be tortured you're going to be deported
uh you're going to be derided all that
and also you're poor because he's rich
like that's a big part of it so while
this was going on and food was becoming
a problem because you had uh you know
for weather conditions
uh there was a campaign about oh the
reason you're hungry is because the
kulaks are hoarding all the grain yeah
uh and if you're somewhere else in in
the Soviet Union how are you supposed to
know any better because you're being
told every year the crops are bumper
crop bumper crop bumper crop but now
there's no food there's no bread and so
you see we produced all this bread it's
not getting to you because the cool
locks are according to grain so there
they came like um in what became known
to haldemore and Applebaum uh who's a
great historian who unfortunately I
disagree with a lot in contemporary
politics but who's done so much great
work about the uh the Soviet Union that
I pretty much give her a blank check and
whatever she wants to say nowadays you
know she wrote a great book about this
called red famine and these activists
descended on these Villages like locusts
and their job was to requisition as much
food as possible and they would come
back you know at all hours of the night
to make sure you weren't hiding food and
this is what was so pernicious about it
your own body would betray you they
could look at you and see that you're
not losing weight you're got those
chubby cheeks that means you have food
and that's the government's food that is
the food of the people and if you are
keeping food for yourself you are
stealing from the people you're an enemy
of the people and you deserve whatever
comes to you and it got to a point where
they're eating they didn't have grain to
plant for the next Harvest
um and what was even sicker is you know
one of the big criticisms of of
Communists of the Czar was his internal
passport system that I can't go wherever
I want within Russia the Russian Empire
without permission uh Stalin
reintroduced this
so if your village was targeted you
can't leave now some people got away
they tried to get to the cities and so
on and so forth but you get to the city
and you're starving you have no clothes
you're a coolock I'm hungry because of
you and now you're too lazy to get the F
out of there and there were stories you
know uh you know I have them in in the
white pill of this like starving teenage
girl and she's begging for food and the
guy knocks the The shopkeep Knocks the
food out of her hand and she dies on the
spot and everyone in that line knew not
to you know give her uh any food or any
sympathy because she's a cool lock
sympathizer and very quickly if you're a
cool lock sympathizer all that has to
happen is someone has to call I think it
was the nkpd at the time you know the
different names for the Checker the
secret police and they had to be like oh
you see uh whatever her name was jenya
she was a kulak sympathizer we saw kulak
who was trying to shake us down for food
because too lazy to work and she uh felt
so bad for them so you might want to
check in on Virginia so yeah
but in 32 and 33 holiday Moore
it wasn't just
um small Injustice here and there it was
mass starvation yes and suffering yes
Millions starve to death in the Ukraine
alone and by Design
so you uh mentioned and applebaum's book
red famine yeah Stars war in Ukraine but
another excellent book on on the topic
and by the way thank you for
recommending that to me so
um her work's amazing yeah it's it's a
really really powerful uh book about not
just about hanamore but like the context
of Ukraine
basically the history of Ukraine that's
relevant for today yeah
to understand understand the the
relationship between Russia and Ukraine
uh but another great book is bloodlands
Europe between Hitler and Stalin by
Timothy I don't know I think you also
recommend that to me at some point or
maybe not I haven't but I'm I'm familiar
with that and read it uh so he he does
quite a bit of is brief but extremely
well researched writing about
cannibalism there okay and that it was
not uncommon during the Stalin imposed
famine in the Soviet Ukraine for parents
to cook and eat their children he writes
quote survival was immoral as well as a
physical struggle a woman doctor wrote
to a friend in June 1933 that she had
not yet become a cannibal but was not
sure that it shall not be won by the
time my letter reaches you
in quotes the good people died first
those who refused to steal or to
prostitute themselves died those who
gave food to others died those who
refused to eat corpses died those who
refused to kill their fellow man died
parents who resisted cannibalism died
before their children did and their
stories in there about
um
yeah cooking cooking your children
uh the the other thing about cannibalism
about famine in general that stood out
to me that unlike a lot of atrocities
is uh the people that are starving are
exhausted they're they're basically
unable to think
so they don't even have the energy to
protest
it's a it's a strange kind of way
to kill thinking in the populace
that that it kind of I suppose it was
obvious
but there's something fundamental about
starvation where it's slowly removes
your Humanity
um
yeah there's a there was a scene in the
book where um
a lot of times people literally go crazy
and there's a scene where Mom it's some
nursing train station was nursing her
kid and she was you know going mad from
hunger and she just starts beating the
crap out of her baby and kicking it and
then she just reverts to normal like
nothing had happened uh yeah Madness
like yeah yeah you lose yeah you lose
your mind yeah yeah and uh I mean I
don't know what the physiological cause
of this it's not it's I think it's you
know if someone has dealt with a
glycogen depletion it affects their mood
things like that so taken to an extreme
who knows what happens when parts of the
brain start functioning and start
imploding